what a night thanks to everybody who
joined me on the livestream by the way
last night on the David Pakman show
YouTube channel thousands and thousands
of people coming through and sending
comments and a lot of people signing up
for memberships to set up for the next
two years because we had results that I
am going to go through in detail
yesterday we have results from the house
we have results from the Senate we have
results very positive results for
Democrats when it comes to governor's
races and we'll talk about ballot
initiatives just so much to discuss
let's start with the house then do
Senate and then we are going to kind of
sum up about the meaning of everything
that happened yesterday and what's next
and what is now possible so in the House
Democrats have won Democrats took over
control of the house there are still
numbers coming in so it's not as of
right now a hundred percent clear
exactly how many seats Democrats picked
up there are websites right now that
have it as plus 26 some is plus 28
others that say it's going to be
somewhere in the 30s when it's all said
and done
Democrats needed to gain 25 seats so at
the conservative end of those numbers
not an overwhelming victory but taking
over the house is taking over the house
gerrymandering is something that when it
comes to the house works against
Democrats and we have to see it as a win
even if it is one that is not as big as
we would have wanted some notable races
Alexandria Acacio Cortez not
surprisingly after defeating the
incumbent Democrat in the Democratic
primary got 78% of the vote in New
York's 14th district will become the
youngest member of the House ever at 29
actually is it ever
she'll be the youngest now I wonder i
believe it also is ever at 29 years old
sadly our friend JD Schulten who was
running in Iowa's fourth district
against Steve King who is one of the
most King is disgusting extreme white
nationalist neo-nazi associated members
of the House of Representatives
JD Shelton who I met in New Orleans at
Netroots nation interviewed him hung out
with him a little bit there such
good guy and would have been such an
amazing victory to take down Steve King
but sadly JT Schulten did not win ending
up just shy about ten thousand votes shy
which in that relatively in that
particular district worked out to fifty
point four to forty seven percent about
three point four percentage points
separating them you know valiant effort
what does that mean right it was close
is it better for it to have been close
than not maybe a because it signals that
even those red districts could be turned
blue I sent JD a message and it's just a
real real disappointment good news from
the house congressman Russia also known
as California's Dana Rohrabacher he lost
to Democratic challenger Harley ruda
that is fantastic news because it not
only is he an extremist Republican he's
also one of the most Russia co-opted
members of the House of Representatives
and it is fantastic that he is on his
way out
and now as soon as Democrats are sworn
in in January it's time to get going and
the question is well what what do we get
going on number one investigations and I
don't mean just Trump we have been
dealing with in the Trump administration
at large not just the White House with
one of the most corrupt self-serving
truth ignoring groups of people that
have maybe ever made up an
administration David corn is already
reporting that House Democrats have
started to put together a list of areas
of investigation and subpoenas related
to the Trump administration the house
has dozens of committees and
subcommittees and they have some serious
investigative power and you are going to
likely see the Intelligence Committee
revive the Trump Russia investigation
but in a serious way not one where
Republican Devin Nunez
Trump's buddy is running back and forth
to the White House telling Trump exactly
what the committee is doing it will be
hopefully a non farcical investigation
you
to see Foreign Affairs hopefully look at
the Trump Saudi relationship and
potential violations of the emoluments
clause with Saudi Arabia but also with a
whole bunch of other countries in their
attempts to ingratiate themselves with
Trump by staying at his hotel in
Washington DC when they come in for
official business the Department of
Homeland Security can get right in the
middle of the policy of child
separations that is being carried out by
the Trump administration at the border
armed services can investigate whether
Trump is violating the law by using the
military as law enforcement when he
sends them to the us-mexico border to
play cops because of the immigrant
Caravan that is quickly dwindling in
size and very slowly approaching the
us-mexico border
Trump's cabinet members could and should
find themselves under investigation
you've got Wilbur Ross
ben Carson Ryan Zinke we've talked about
Betsy DeVos they've all been accused of
wrongdoing they all should be
investigated by the house if Donald
Trump found fake news an annoyance in
doing whatever the hell he wants I think
he doesn't yet know what it's like to
have a opposition House of
Representatives investigating you in a
serious manner and then there are even
more I mean oversight and government
reform they've got a very long list of
things they want to investigate Trump
about this includes why are they adding
a citizenship question to the census and
what are the motivations for doing that
what about the endless White House
security clearance scandals what about
the Muslim travel ban what about that
ambush in Nazaire that left four
soldiers dead and the Trump Foundation
and Trump's response to the puerto rican
hurricane use of private even at private
email by the white house all of this
stuff is now on the table and then put
all of that aside then there's the House
Judiciary Committee and they have
another list which I'm not even going to
get into right now
and what I absolutely believe we need to
demand of Democrats when they take over
control of
House of Representatives they must
investigate the racially tinged voter
purges that have taken place in states
all across the country it's time to use
the subpoena power this is an attack on
our democracy there are attacks on our
democracy happening from foreign powers
and there are attacks on our democracy
for the benefit of the Republican Party
happening internally and then in
addition to the investigations can we
take control of the 2020 census back
because that has become a disaster under
Donald Trump can we take control or
prevent more outrageous tax reform bills
all of these possibilities are now on
the table because the Democratic Party
is taking over control of the House of
Representatives we will be speaking
about this a lot more later in the
program I'm really excited to tell you
about one of today's sponsors fare
indigo calm you've heard me talk about
them before they are offering 15% off
your first order only when you use promo
code Pakman at checkout most people in
our audience know that workers rights
abuses pollution these are massive
issues in the garment industry and we've
covered it before fair indigo calm is a
clothing company that has taken a stand
on these issues they make clothing from
premium alpaca and ultra high-quality
organic pima cotton which is the softest
and longest lasting cotton on earth and
it's grown by small-scale farmers
without any pesticides everything is
manufactured in eco-friendly artists and
workshops in Lima Peru that pay their
workers fair living wages if you're
watching on YouTube right now I am
wearing the alpaca baseball sweater and
I love it get compliments everywhere I
go unfair indigo you'll find everything
from men's short and long sleeve
t-shirts polo sweaters hoodies even
belts and wallets made from recycled
materials to women's tops pants dresses
and scarves you should have no trouble
finding something that will fit
style and beyond workers rights and
sustainability fair Indigo's specialty
is extreme quality everything they sell
is meant to last you a lifetime
click the link under this video shipping
is always free on orders over $75 and
you'll save 15% when you use the promo
code PA que ma n at checkout